Speaker 1: I really hate to do this because
he's a super nice guy who I've actually had
dinner with in a group and we have a lot of
contacts and friends in common.
But Robert F Kennedy Jr.
Bobby Kennedy Jr has launched a completely
off the rails presidential campaign based
on anti-vaxx opportunism and pro-Putin talking
points.
And it's really, really sad that this is going
on.
As I've mentioned before on the show, Bobby
kennedy jr is sort of like linked to other
folks that are in progressive media.
And I once had dinner with him in Las Vegas
and he was super nice and engaging, told interesting
stories, extraordinarily polite and just a
nice guy to be around.
And then the pandemic hit and what has what
was before sort of a more casual skepticism
of vaccines became going fully.
Anti-vaxx recently pictured with Michael Flynn,
just completely embraced by the most extreme
anti-vaccine elements.
And earlier this month, Bobby Kennedy filed
his candidacy, making him the fourth member
of his family to seek the presidency of the
United States.
He had an event yesterday in Boston in which
he, quite frankly, ranted for 90 minutes to
the point where even people behind him were
starting to become visibly uncomfortable.
Here is Bobby Kennedy Junior praising Donald
Trump's instincts not to close the country
down during COVID.
Take a listen.
Speaker 5: President Trump said, well, these
bureaucrats came at him for every side and
they were all telling him he had to do it.
He had the right instincts.
He knew that he shouldn't close down the country,
but he did it.
He got rolled.
I is bureaucracy.
And I'm going to tell you a quick story.
I'm hearing the Cuban Missile Crisis.
Speaker 1: Yeah, there were a lot of those
side stories, which is why this thing ended
up lasting an hour and a half.
It is important to mention that there is wide
reporting that many members of the Kennedy
family are supporting joe Biden over Bobby
Kennedy Jr in the primary.
And I guess I should mention Bobby Kennedy
Junior running as a Democrat, although I don't
really know at this point, sort of like what
policies line him up with the Democratic Party.
Here is a clip sort of in the middle of this
extremely long 90 minute rant.
And as you can see, the folks in the background,
their expressions have changed pretty dramatically.
And it was it was quite painful.
I will say.
I'm in a.
Speaker 5: Lawsuit involving Amazon for censoring
one of my books.
So they were censoring people who criticized
the White House while they were raking in
the money from the left.
Speaker 1: And I it's hard not to laugh because
the crowd he lost the crowd the way Trump
loses a crowd just going on and on.
And yes, he talks about he's being censored
and now he's he's going to fight back with
censoring.
What on earth is going on here?
This is what.
Speaker 5: This is what happens when you censor
somebody for 18 years.
Unidentified: I got a lot to talk.
Speaker 5: Hey, should they shut me up that
long?
Because now I've got really let loose on him.
So the next 18 months, they're going to hear
a lot from me.
Speaker 1: So, listen, I support anybody who
wants to challenge Joe Biden for the Democratic
nomination.
Absolutely.
Do it.
Here's just a guy who I can't say is a better
alternative to me in absolutely any way.
He, of course, got the hero's welcome on Tucker
Carlson's program last night after this very
brave launching of an anti-vax campaign for
president.
And what he did was he showed up on Tucker
Carlson's show and he repeated pro-Putin propaganda
about death rates in the invasion of Ukraine
by Russia.
Speaker 5: Nobody talks about this.
There's 14,000 Ukrainian civilians who have
died.
300,000 troops.
Russians are killing Ukrainians at a 7 to
1 8 to 1 ratio.
They cannot sustain this.
What we're being told about this war is just
not true.
Speaker 4: No, it's not true.
Speaker 1: There you go.
So finding common ground with the pro-Putin
people and with Tucker Carlson, this is a
claim based on a fake doctored report of Russian
propaganda put out that has been conclusively
debunked and it is still being repeated by
bobby kennedy jr.
To tucker carlson.
So essentially an anti-vaxx pro-Putin campaign.
I guess it is truly sad to see this bobby
kennedy Jr.
Not only a really nice guy, but a long history
of powerful work, defending the environment,
protecting the planet, dealing with climate
change.
Riverkeeper alliance attorney working on these
issues.
It's genuinely depressing to see what has
happened with Bobby Kennedy Jr.
And also, I guess now at his rally, his wife,
the actress from Curb Your Enthusiasm and
other shows, Cheryl Hines, was there and and
introduced him and seemed to be behind the
whole thing.
There was quite a bit of drama involving her
during the the heart of the pandemic, wherein
while Bobby Kennedy Jr was out rallying railing
against vaccines, Cheryl required everyone
who went to their holiday party to be vaccinated.
And sort of it seemed as though maybe she
wasn't on board with the entire thing, but
apparently now she is.
So this is not a candidate I will be supporting.
I don't yet know who I will be supporting
in the Democratic primary because I don't
yet know who all the candidates are going
to be.
Joe Biden has not even announced that he is
running for reelection.
So when I know who I will be supporting, I
will let you know.
The first step would be let's figure out if
Joe Biden is actually running
for reelection.